well both what it is it clearly has
something to do with brains or it's
something that emerges from brains when
brains get sufficiently big presumably
as human brains have consciousness seems
to emerge as to what it is that's
philosophically a very difficult
question which biologists are no more
equipped to deal with them than anybody
else
Oh nobody knows because we don't know
which animals are conscious we don't
actually technically even know that any
other human being is conscious but just
each of us know that we ourselves are
conscious we infer on pretty good
grounds that other people are conscious
and it's the same sort of grounds that
lead us to infer that probably
chimpanzees a conscience and probably
dogs are conscious but when we come to
something like earthworms and snails
it's anybody's guess
well that's a very difficult question
since we can't actually measure where
the creatures are conscious so I guess
science has as much insight as any other
subject but I don't think I can answer
that question directly maybe computer
science has as much insight into it as
any other science